et al ouais très clair les 10 vous
pourriez rassembler où les les yeux dans
les yeux
est ce que vous pourriez être candidate
c'est une probabilité c'est une
probabilité c'est une probabilité forte
probabilité forte probabilité est en
passe de faire en sorte que ça soit une
forte probabilité et on ne passe pas
mais j'ai toujours dit si quelqu'un
d'autre est mieux à même que moi de
rassembler gagner je me mettrais
derrière mais alors qu'ils essaient
aussi c'était une forte probabilité et
c'est possible aujourd'hui
emmanuel macron la montre et d'une
certaine façon vous n'êtes plus au parti
socialiste doit c'est justement ce se
porter candidat sans avoir un groupe la
partie derrière soi personne ne doute
que je suis socialiste
non bien sûr mais dans mais si c'est le
cas si je suis candidate ce sera une
décision collective puisqu'il faut
rassembler à la fois le parti socialiste
les verts peut-être d'autres jusqu'à la
fin jusqu'à la france a sonné mais bien
sûr je pense qu'il faut essayer d'avoir
tout le monde vous êtes une partie des
centristes vous arrivez à vous entendre
avec jean luc mélenchon en tout cas il
faut il faut essayer
vous parlez beaucoup et on ne peut lui
parle on ne peut rien depuis longtemps
puisqu'on était dans le même
gouvernement
je ne peut réussir que si nous sommes
unis cm et pas réussir pour nous pour
que les français est un choix alternatif
à l'élection le mot de la fin
présidentielle le moulin de personne ne
peut me reprocher de ne pas être
écologiste et les termes de la question
sera la suivante est-ce que ça vous
paraît imaginables envisageable que au
deuxième tour en 2022 donc ça ne soit
pas le match retour de ce qui s'est
passé en 2010 est c'est-à-dire emmanuel
macron et marine le pen
mais si bien pour empêcher ça qu'il faut
et qu'il faut proposer une alternance de
me dire à moi je suis ancien monde etc
mais je pense que l'arrivée d'une femme
à la présidence de la république
française c'est un plafond bas c'était
justement c'est pour justement vous
aimeriez est ce qu'on aimerait que ce
soit marine le pen la première femme
président la république
non et le fait c'est juste tellement
révolutionnaire surtout dans un pays
comme la france de faire accéder une
femme aux responsabilités
présidentielles je pense que le moment
est venu bien plus de chance d'être au
deuxième tour d'après vos manuels macro
marine le pen c'est impossible à dire
pour l'instant merci mme olive forte
probabilité d'être candidat présidentiel
vous le saurez quand vous décidez
construit ça vous le cidre et auront
besoin d'accords déciderai quand c'est
quoi la delta et ses sus c'est un procès
s'il ya un moment tu sais la politique
c'est un processus on n'y a pas de date
limite et yaya payet non il n'y a pas de
date en politique merci issus encore si
ségolène royal intelligence collective
merci ségolène royal
[Musique]